who's the greatest comic of all time
well i don't think there is a greatest
comic of all time
it's like mcdonald
nor macdonald was one of the greats for
sure but by the way actually on that
topic what what do you think about his i
think as a person who is fascinated by
the fear of death and death i think it
was
a truly
genius thing to release a special after
you're dead
i don't know how that works i haven't
seen the special view it's not yeah it's
it's um
it's called i think nothing special
which sounds like something normal
and it's basically him in front of i
mean i i imagine he wouldn't would have
wanted it edited that way because it's
made to look nicer than i think he
probably would have preferred it
uh but it's him in front of the
screen like in a zoom call
doing jokes
without lap cold really yeah and
somehow given his
like dry dark humor it works
because it's almost making fun of itself
almost making fun of that hole that we
were stuck
stuck alone inside
and because he's still acting as if he's
in front of the audience and is almost
making fun of the fact that this is what
we're forced to do i mean it's quite
genius it's really well and the jokes
are really good but it also makes you
realize how important laughter is from
the audience the energy from the
audience
because uh but there's also an intimacy
because it's just you and him
because you're listening to it you know
there's no audience yeah so that's i
don't know it's i think it's quite
genius and he's of course there's
there's certain comics that are like
not only are they funny
but they're truly unique
and
like they're they're they're
not in terms of uh friendship and all
that kind of stuff but in terms of
comedy they're an island yeah they you
know mitch hedberg probably is that of
course a lot of people then start to
imitate them and so on but stephen
wright stephen wright
i mean there's like people who are like
you know dave chappelle who's
like probably one of the greats but he's
just like raw funny yeah i don't know if
he's an island
he's just raw oh yeah i know what you're
saying an outlier a unique
individual yeah he's just great
um
norm was definitely unique in his
greatness like like there's only one
norm you know who's got a very specific
style is there a reason you guys weren't
he doesn't seem like he was you guys
were close
i mean i loved him he was great i always
enjoyed talking to him
um
we just didn't work together that often
we weren't around each other that often
that's all it was but it wasn't like uh
it was i loved him though
he was a great guy i had a funny story
about it norm uh twice just randomly i
was on airplanes next to him
seated right next to him just totally
random yeah and uh one time
we're on this uh airplane and we're
having this talk and i was like yeah i
quit smoking i was smoking a lot and i
just
yeah it's terrible terrible smoke it's
terrible for you
and we have this great conversation we
get off the plane and he sprints towards
a store and buys cigarettes like in the
airport and is lighting it on the way
out the door and i go i thought you quit
smoking it was yeah i did but all that
talking about smoking made me wanted to
smoke again
before he's getting through the door of
the airport he's lighting it up i can't
wait
he can't wait to get that cigarette at
him it was he's just
so crazy and
impulsive and
loved to gamble he loved gambling and in
that way he embodied the joke like you
can't even tell that certain people just
like live
in a non-sequitur
ridiculous absurd
funny way yeah that was him i mean
non-stop just there was nothing
artificial about norm you know that that
was who he was
his brilliance was
his essence that was who he was
you know but it's in terms of like the
greats
the godfather of it all is lenny bruce i
mean i have a bunch of lenny bruce
concert posters at my house and photos
that i have framed and whitney cummings
actually gave me this brilliant photo of
him uh when he got arrested for one of
the times when he got arrested for
saying obscene jokes
he was the most important figure in the
early days of comedy because he
essentially gave birth to the modern art
form of standup comedy before that was a
bunch of guys that were like hosting
shows and they would tell jokes they
were just like you know
you know two guys walking to a bar that
kind of stuff yeah and
he would talk about
social issues you know he would talk
about life he would talk about language
he would talk about
laws
and it was just he was uh
the very first guy who did modern stand
up and what's fascinating is if you go
and you try to watch it
if you try to watch lenny bruce today it
doesn't work
because society has evolved like in many
ways art is a window especially like pop
culture art or modern
uh
you know at the time culture uh
art
art that discusses culture is a window
into that time period it's a little bit
of a time machine so you get to like you
have to put yourself like what was it
like to be in 1963 like what was he say
in 1963 what was this like to hear him
say this
and
the
the civilization that existed in 1963
although it looked pretty similar
they're all driving cars and they're all
wearing suits and they're all it seems
normal that's a it's a different world
and the things that he was saying that
are so taboo are so normal today yeah
that they're not shocking and it's not
not that good it's not that funny yeah
you have to do the same kind of stuff
for um
like there's d.h lawrence has a book
called lady shatterley's lover
and i know it sounds ridiculous but it
was one of the early books i believe at
the
uh
over a century ago that was very
controversial for its sexual content
it's sort of one of the great books
because it dared to actually talk about
a woman cheating on her husband
and like and do so
in the highest form and the same thing
with gulag archipelago talking about
talking about some of the darkest
aspects of human history
right when all of that stuff is
forbidden
when it's banned because now it's like
not you know
yes we all know this history but when in
the middle of it when you're risking
your own life when you're risking your
book being banned or burned or
you being imprisoned that's when it
matters like taking that risk yeah and
no one took that risk more than lenny
bruce lenny bruce was arrested many many
times and
ultimately it wound up costing him his
life i mean he died on the bathroom
floor shooting heroin and trying to cope
with all the lawsuits that he was going
through i mean this guy was constantly
being arrested and constantly going
through lawsuits and then his comedy
deteriorated horribly there's some
footage of him
towards the end of his career where he's
essentially go on stage with legal
papers and read from the legal papers
about his case
from then it's richard pryor from him
then the next great is richard pryor and
he had the most profound impact on me
when i was a kid when i was 15 years old
my parents took me to see live at the
sunset strip which is a richard pryor's
concert film and i
remember very distinctly being in that
audience
and laughing and looking around at all
the people in the audience who were like
falling out of their chairs just
dying laughing just swaying back and
forth and i was laughing hard too and i
was like my god this guy is doing this
just by talking
i thought of all the great movies that
i'd seen that i loved that were
hilarious comedy movies
and i was like nothing that i've ever
seen is as funny as this and all he's
doing is talking
and that planted a seed in my head for
my love of stand-up comedy and my
curiosity about the art form and that's
what got me interested in you know
watching it on television and then
ultimately going to open mic nights and
then eventually doing it
you